these families left venezuela hoping for
a new life
in chile back home life had become
unbearable
they say there's no food no jobs and no
future
you can't survive in venezuela you
really can't how are we supposed to make
it with about three dollars a month
now there are fears of a potential
humanitarian crisis
entire communities are walking towards
the chilean border
climbing mountains and rocky grounds to
avoid border checkpoints
at least two people died attempting the
journey one from colombia
the other from venezuela
about 30 people who were in the group
tried to help one of the migrants with
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation
but it's possible the patient had
covered nineteen so now
there's a risk the virus has spread more
than four million people have fled
venezuela in recent years
most went to colombia and peru but now
more families are choosing to go to
prosperous chile
but not everyone is happy to see them
families from our local aimaras
indigenous group have had intruders in
their properties
they walk in looking for food and
clothes they go through peru and they
arrive to chile in deplorable conditions
chilean soldiers have been deployed
along bolivia's border to prevent
illegal crossings
but stopping them has been a challenge
most refugees and migrants say their
desire
for a new start is stronger than the
fear of the dangerous journey
katya lopez odeon al jazeera